can you
take us through what social media
content algorithms have done
uh sure yeah so
the social media content algorithms
right they decide
what you read and what you watch
and
they do that for
literally billions of people
for hours every day
right um so in that sense they have more
control
over human
cognitive input
than any dictator in history
has ever had more than stalin more than
kim il-sung
more than hitler
right they have massive
uh power over human beings
and they're completely unregulated
and people are
reasonably concerned about
what effect they're having um
and so what they do
um is basically they they set an
objective because they're
good standard model machine learning
algorithms and so they're set and
objective let's say maximize click
through right the the probability that
you're going to click on the next thing
so imagine it's like this is youtube
uh you know you watch your video and lo
and behold another video pops up
right and am i going to watch the next
video that it sends me to watch or am i
going to you know close the window
and
so click through or you know engagement
or various other metrics these are the
things that the algorithm is trying to
optimize
and
i suspect originally
the the companies thought
well this is good because it's good for
us if they click on things we make money
uh and it's good for people because the
algorithm will learn to send people
stuff they're interested in if they
click on it it's because they wanted to
click on it yeah right and there's no
point sending them stuff that they don't
like they're just cluttering up their
their input so to speak um
but
you know i think the algorithms had
other ideas
and uh
the way
um
that an algorithm maximizes
click-through in the long run is not
just by learning what you want
right because
you are not a fixed thing
and so
though you can get more
long-run
click-throughs
if
you change the person
into someone who's more predictable
right who's
uh for example you know addicted to a
certain kind of violent pornography
right and so youtube can make you into
that person
by
you know
gradually sending you you know the
gateway drugs and then
more and more
uh extreme content whatever direction so
the algorithm doesn't know that you're a
human being or you have a brain
right as far as it's concerned you're
just a string of clicks
right
content click content click content clip
right and um
but it wants to turn you into a string
of clicks that in the long run there's
more clicks and less
less non-clicks and so it learns to
change people
into
more extreme more more predictable
mainly but it turns out probably more
extreme
versions of themselves so if you know if
you
indicate that you're interested in
climate science it might
try to turn you into an eco-terrorist
you know and
you set you know articles full of
outrage and
um
[Music]
and so on if if you're interested in in
cars it might try to turn you into
someone who just watches endless
uh and endless reruns of top gear why is
the person that's extreme more
predictable
well i this i think this is a this is
that's an empirical hypothesis on
on my part right that
if you're more extreme you're you have a
higher
emotional response
to content that affirms your
uh your current views of the world and
so what in politics we call it red meat
right the
um
the kind of content that gets the base
riled up about you know whatever it is
that i love about whether it's the
environment or or you know immigrants
flooding our shores or whatever it might
be right you know if once you
once you get the sense that someone
might be a little bit upset about
too many immigrants then you you send
them stuff about all the bad things that
immigrants do and you know you know
videos of people climbing over walls and
uh sneaking into beaches and all the
rest of the stuff you know and it's
human propagandists have known this
forever
but
historically human propagandists could
only produce one message
whereas the content algorithms can
produce
in theory one propaganda stream for each
human being
specially tailored to them
and
the algorithm knows how you engage with
every single piece of content
right your typical
you know hitler's propagandist sitting
in berlin had absolutely no idea
on a moment-to-moment basis how people
were reacting
uh to the stuff that they were
broadcasting right they could see it in
the aggregate over longer periods of
time
um that certain
certain kinds of content was effective
uh in the aggregate but they don't have
anything like the degree of control
that that these algorithms have
and
you know the
one of the strange things is that we
actually have very little insight
into what the algorithms are actually
doing so what i've described to you
seems to be a
logical consequence of how the
algorithms operate and what they're
trying to maximize
um but i don't have hard empirical
evidence
that this is really what's happening to
people um because the the platforms are
pretty opaque
but they're
they're opaque to themselves
they're a picture themselves so you know
facebook's over own oversight board
doesn't have access
to the algorithms and the data
uh to see what's going on who does
i think um
the engineers
but their job is to maximize
click-through
right
so
pretty much there isn't anyone
who
doesn't already have a vested interest
in this who has access
to what's happening and and that i think
is something that we're trying to fix
um
both at the government level
so there's uh there's this new
organization called the global
partnership on ai
which is
um
you know it could just be you know yet
another do goody talking shop but it
actually has government representatives
sitting on it so
it can make
direct policy recommendations to
governments
um and it ha in some sense it has the
force of governments behind it when it's
talking to
the facebooks and googles of the world
so we're in the process
of seeing if we can develop agreements
between governments and platforms
uh for a certain type of transparency so
it doesn't mean
you know looking at whatever you know
looking at what chris is is watching on
youtube you do not want to do that you
do not want to do that
it means
um
you know being able to find out you know
how much terrorist content
uh is is being pumped out where is it
coming from who is it going to
uh slightly more sort of aggregated
stuff like typical data scientists do
yeah so and and
possibly being able to do some kinds of
experiments
like you know if
if the recommendation algorithm works
this way
you know what effects do we see on users
compared to an algorithm that works in a
different way so to me that's the
really interesting question
um
is
you know how do the recommendation
algorithms work and what effect do they
have on people
um and if we find
that they really are manipulating people
right that they're
they're sort of a consistent drift
um that a person who starts in a
particular place
will get driven in some direction that
they might not have wanted to be driven
in
then that's really a problem and we have
to think about different algorithms and
so in ai we often distinguish between
reinforcement learning algorithms
which
are trying to maximize a long-term sum
of rewards so
so in this case the long-term rate of
clicks
on the content stream is what the
algorithm is trying to maximize those
kinds of algorithms by definition
will
manipulate
because the
the action that they can take is to
choose a particular piece of content to
send you
and then
the state of the world that they are
trying to change is your brain
and so they will learn to do it
right a supervised learning algorithm
is one
that's trying to
get it right
right now
right so they are trying to
um
predict whether or not you're going to
click on a given piece of content
right so a supervised learning algorithm
that learns a good model of what you
will and won't click on
could be used
to decide what to send you in a way
that's not based on reinforcement
learning and long-term maximization but
simply
okay given a model of what you're likely
to click on will send you something
that's consistent with that model
right
in that case
i think you could have you could imagine
that it would work in such a way that it
wouldn't move you it wouldn't cause you
to change
your preferences but
um
if it was done right could sort of leave
you roughly where you are
um are you familiar with the term
audience capture you know what this
means from a creator an online creator's
perspective
uh
i can imagine but not as not as a
technical term yeah well it's not it's
not a technical term but it's basically
when you have a particular creator
online who
finds a message
narrative rhetoric that resonates with
the audience and what you see is that
this particular creator becomes captured
and they start to feed
their own audience a message that they
know is going to be increasingly more
well liked and for the most part this
actually does look like a slide toward
one side of the
one particular direction or the other at
least politically it does but with
anything it does too that people
inevitably sort of niche down and then
they bring their audience along with it
so the fascinating thing here i mean
first off it's
unbelievable
that these algorithms that are simply
there to try and maximize time on site
or click-throughs or watch time or
whatever
that they have managed to find a way
things that we programmed managed to
find a way to program us for it to be
able to do its job better
i mean that when i read that in your
book i
it's insane like that's one of the most
terrifying things that and it's
happening right it happened like
everybody that's listening to this has
had something occur with regards to
their preferences their world view
whatever it might be something has slid
in one way or another you may be right
it may not be toward the extremes
i would say anecdotally based on what i
see in the world increasing sort of um
levels of partisanship no matter what it
is whether it be sports politics
race relations
anything uh people are moving toward the
extremes why is this happening oh well
you know it's people getting into echo
chambers and they're only being shown
stuff like that
and also the fact
that the algorithms are actually trying
to make them more predictable but on top
of that as well there's another layer
which is the creation of the content
itself that comes in from the creators
and they
have
their own levels of manipulation which
is occurred from their feed
then they kind of second order that into
what do i want to create what have i
seen that's successful what does my
audience seem to resonate with from me
so you have layers and layers of
manipulation going on here
yeah yeah and i think i you know in some
ways the creators are are being
manipulated by the system
um you know i think every journalist now
is thinking
okay
i have to get something that's clickbait
i have to
write an article that can have a
headline that is sufficiently attractive
that it'll get clicked on you know and
it's almost the point where the you know
the headline and the article are
completely divorced from each other um
and and and you can see this now in the
comments right the the people writing
the comments at the end of the article
will say oh i'm really i'm really pissed
off this is just click bait you know the
article really doesn't say anything
about the thing you said you were going
to say
so on so
so
this
you know it was not as if this has never
been going on and obviously you can't
you can't ban people from writing
interesting articles or you know i often
think about you know the novel and it
says on the back i couldn't put it down
right well she'll be banned
novels are here because that's addictive
you know you can't have that right uh no
but i think
it wasn't too bad before
because
the
feedback loop was very slow
and
there wasn't this you know
targeting of individuals by algorithms
who are you know so you think about the
the number of learning opportunities for
the algorithm
right i mean it's billions every day for
the youtube
uh selection algorithm right so it's
the
the amount
the consistency
the frequency and the customization of
the learning opportunities for
manipulation
so much
greater i mean it's you know millions or
billions of times greater and more
systematic
and that that systematic element so it
reminds me there's this i don't know if
it's apocryphal but there's a
um there's a story about the psychology
lecturer and he's been teaching the
students
about subliminal
uh effects
and the you know the students decide to
play a trick on him
which is you know every every time he's
on the left-hand side of the room they
pay attention they're really interested
and every time he walks onto the
right-hand side of the room they all
really bored you know start checking out
the email and so
and uh and by the end of the lecture
he's glued against the left hand
right and he has no idea that he's being
manipulated
um but because of the fact that this was
like systematic
and uh you know and sufficiently
frequent it has a very very strong
effect
uh you know and i think that
that's the difference here is that it's
because it's algorithmic
um
and it's tied into this very high
frequency interaction
uh that people have with social media it
has a huge effect
um and it has i think a pretty rapid
effect as well
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace
you